during routine maintenance on the police
national computer
a rogue piece of code found its way into
the system
the result hundreds of thousands of
fingerprint
dna and case records were deleted
the government has called it human error
but it could have far
reaching consequences our job now over
the next
few days is to recover the data which
was erroneously deleted
um and to make sure that what remains on
the on the computer is sound
and can be used by police officers or
what we've said to those who are
currently relying on pnc data for
investigations is that once we've done
that
they can rerun their searches and
hopefully get the result that they need
in a leaked letter the national police
chief's council said 213
000 records were deleted along with
around 175
000 arrest files 26 000
dna records relating to crimes deleted
as well as thirty thousand fingerprint
files gone
it's understood that experts in the
recovery of deleted data
are now helping the home office find a
way of clawing back these files
but if it turns out that that
information cannot be retrieved
then that would have huge implications
for the justice system
for example criminals who otherwise
would have been convicted
could go free and that would deprive
victims
of their right to justice tonight the
home secretary released a statement
saying
home office engineers continue to work
to restore data lost
as a result of human error during a
routine housekeeping process
earlier this week public safety is the
number one priority of everyone within
the home office
and i would like to thank the data
engineers working to restore these
records
some of these now involve live cases
investigations that are going on
now so this isn't just a historic record
it's a record that is relevant or some
of them are relevant to
ongoing investigations and um the home
secretary needs to take responsibility
for that
gary langrish is a former detective now
specialist in data protection
the worry also is when people uh submit
to
local forces police background checks
for
certain types of jobs like working with
children or the vulnerable
there may be some gaps there so no doubt
police forces will be putting a hold on
some of those checks
and revisit them in the future experts
now say the potential loss of so much
data
reveals a serious flaw in the system and
is likely to lead to a review
of how criminal case information is
stored in the future
nick martin sky news